but uh there's you know there to be
you know beginning uh this effort uh for
2021 is uh i think we've learned a few
lessons from
last year as well there's help us we
they're
you know being there to help uh clear
roads rebuild
main streets uh and so that the families
can get back to their lives uh
that's what fema does every single day
nailed it
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
all right so as we
report on the crisis at the border we've
overlooked a crisis
between our borders domestic migration
americans who are moving from one state
to another also known as sweet
freedom we touched on it last week
here's the big problem yeah domestic
migration
do you know what that is is people
moving from one place to another yes
and but they bring
[Laughter]
he's right but but they're bringing
their bad ideas with them god if i was
any dumber i'd be nicole wallace
so it's the cause and effect that comes
from being over taxed
under protected and treated like crap
it's like you're permanently
living on a delta flight as david kelt
in the american spectator reports
california new york new jersey michigan
and illinois all states in the union cat
lost a combined 4 million residents and
that's not even including gun or coveted
victims
they're losing people quicker than cnn's
prime time
meanwhile republican-led states like
florida texas
tennessee ohio and arizona saw large
increases
that's from the u.s census bureau which
is likely underestimating this shift
since who fills out a census form when
they're in the er with a knife wound
sitting next to the guy who knifed you
but this mass
exodus from blue to red raises the key
question
how much aggravation will this migration
bring to the resident population
what do these new neighbors bring with
them besides their arms are made for
hugging bumper stickers
and they're hankering for responsibly
raised chicken
well they're used to being taxed
california has the highest income tax
rate in
america at 13.3 percent all of it goes
to gavin newsom's hair products
god forbid a duck ever gets stuck in
that mess
they're also used to uh they're also
used to anti-gun laws that prevent you
from protecting your family
as crime stores in manhattan and police
are making fewer arrests
i still can't get a gun from my
apartment and i'm a huge star
on basic cable who does get death
threats
mostly from tyrus when he catches
he catches me trying on his pants
now compare that to the places these
people are moving to
florida texas and tennessee they have no
income tax
no income tax i don't even know what
that's like it must be like doing a
wonderful drug
meanwhile texas lawmakers just approved
a measure allowing people
to carry handguns without a license fact
check me on this but i believe
even your gun is required to wear a
smaller gun
so you have more money in your pocket
and basically people will leave you
alone
purely for safety reasons that is heaven
the opposite of a blue state in
california
with violent crime lost jobs businesses
closing lockdowns homelessness
suddenly the city by the bay looks like
the city by the bay of pigs
it's nowhere to raise a family unless
your kids really like camping
in 2020 over 135 000 people fled
california
in their feces and crusted crocs that's
more people who have seen joy reid's
show in seven years
it's so bad there that when you step in
dog poop you think
i'm so glad it's dog poop of course
the rich libs don't care the homeless
will never get past their gate
the gate that does the exact same thing
is trump's wall that they've been
calling racist for the last four years
meanwhile 3.57 million people left new
york city
357 rather ironic since if they could
have owned guns
many would have stayed new york used to
be a tourist destination
but what's to see besides people being
attacked in times square
maybe that's a whole new type of tourism
live crime
you'll have a great story if you survive
but
but what about broadway greg well who
wants to get slashed by a homeless guy
while waiting in line
i'm going to see death of a salesman not
death of a customer
the big apple has become the big sleep
murders jumped 45 percent from 2019 to
2020
with a nearly 100 percent increase in
shootings seems like the only businesses
making money
are funeral homes new york has lost 34
billion dollars in revenue due to this
exodus
that's more than i make in a year and
let's not forget
new jersey nearby i know we want to with
the most coveted deaths per capita even
with strict lockdowns
and then you got michigan to become a
joke with massive unemployment and it's
silly governor scolding citizens
while she cavorts masculists with
friends and then of course there's
chicago with a mayor who thinks racism
is a solution
to rising homicides and shootings i
wonder
what the angry white male has to say
[Music]
yeah i suppose i would consider moving
then there's always option two
buy a lot of supplies and declare my
basement my own country
ugh if he was any whiter he'd be bret
bear's teeth
so what's the what's the angry black
male have to say
[Music]
[Laughter]
so
people um leaving the blue stage moving
to the red states huh
yeah no kidding that's what i did
oh yeah been there done that
so i guess y'all be uh
my neighbors
[Laughter]
howdy neighbor
[Music]
so will those who leave bring their
louis vuitton bags filled with bad ideas
with them
and if they do how do you a texan a
floridian a tennessean
stop them turns out maybe you can't but
what you can do as a friendly neighbor
is introduce them to the finer points of
life start with a bundt cake in the
shape of a glock
a housewarming gift if you will tell
them it's loaded with whiskey and gluten
then maybe show them how to use your bb
gun on local varmints
see it's baby steps that's the gateway
drug to freedom
then take them shooting before you know
they'll be putting a gun rack on
junior's stroller
and if they don't do it for them that's
only neighborly
let's welcome tonight's guest we call
him loverboy because he's always working
for the weekend
fox and friends weekend co-host and host
of the will game podcast
will come
he's the only money expert we trust with
our swear jar
bonds and group founder and national
review writer david boston
she'd be woke if it weren't for all the
ambien boss news contributor
captain
he hands back the menu and says yes
my massive side ticket hosted up central
park station tyrus
i can you know tyrus uh
pertaining to the angry blackmailing
what advice would you give to your
neighbor if your neighbor comes from a
blue state
stay off my grass i'm not joining any of
your clubs
i don't want to hear a funny story and i
don't want to hear about any of your
other black friends
[Applause]
act accordingly there you go i think
that's pretty i mean that's basically
all you can ask for
that is true exactly the one thing i
learned very quickly
going from california to louisiana
we all mind our own business there i
mean we're cool everyone knows everybody
good morning but it's
short anything longer that's liberal and
everyone stares at you you're allowed
about
15 to 20 seconds to get your good
mornings in and then you can make a
comment about the trees growing a little
bit over
yeah if you want to look at it this
weekend yeah i'll get to that and that's
about it
yes don't don't don't act brand new act
like you're supposed to be there and
just
it's okay for uncomfortable silences
when two guys get in their trucks going
to work it's fine
you don't have to fill it with hey did
you see what was going on in the
sports yesterday yes i know you don't
watch sports because you said did you
see what's going on in the sports
you know just just relax libs just relax
we
we're accepting just don't you know act
like you own the place or be sadder than
me
yeah you know i saw that nestle special
on slavery bro
that's going to piss me off will you
still live in texas
yes still live in texas born and raised
in texas lived here for 15 years and now
i'm part of this statistic you're
quoting i left new york in january
like tyrus to get back to my roots and
to get back to a red state and my advice
is
assimilate what you said last weekend
you moved here for a reason
don't bring the reasons that you left
the last place to this place
assimilate yes but however here's the
problem there's a combination of
stockholm syndrome and amnesia
they leave and then they forget why they
left and then they they kind of like
almost
replant the bad ideas that's the weird
thing i can say there's a legitimate
concern i don't know about louisiana but
there's
definite legitimate concern in texas
among the natives
that this place is going to get changed
all these people moving from california
to blue yeah
no and here's what i've learned and
here's what they've said there's two
different groups of people moving to
texas there are those that are moving
because they're escaping
a lockdown state they're moving to a
free state and those people
understand and are ready to be free the
people that are moving for economic
conditions their jobs have pulled them
down to texas
those are the ones you have to worry
about who are bringing their politics
with them
is there any way david to like stop them
from from from watching this i think
it's happening in austin where you where
do you live
so i'm half the time here in manhattan
half the time in newport beach
california
so i'm like taking one for the team here
in both states like i'm doing everything
wrong
right but no i think the reality is you
said it when people don't want the crime
and they don't want the taxes the
regulation
i think they take some of those things
they won't take all of them it's like
when all of it piles on together
but you look at arizona is going to have
more californians in
the phoenix area in a few years than it
has arizonans that that blue state to
red state deal
is real but i think for the most part
even when they go for economic reasons
i still think they kind of know we want
at least a sort of purple state
mentality i don't think it's it's
totally sociological that they want all
the blue state
stuff they left it hasn't happened yet
no states are totally flipped from
migration
i was in a purple state once okay
you don't even know what i was talking
about i know where it's going and i'm
saying no
look i read about it it's your turn i
read about it in a magazine
of course you do go that way was the
magazine had a fruit named by any chance
[Applause]
yo cat what people don't understand is
that
it's not just a contrast in services but
also who you share your services with
for example if you were to go to the
hospital for an emergency
in a nice suburban town you might be
fine but in midtown manhattan
you could be in hell yep went through
that last night
and it wasn't how uh you know husbands
you know
infected bug bite leg exploded very
disgusting or so he says yeah
who gets an infected bug it's called
cellulitis i can send you some photos
while you're eating if you want
uh and it was great we went there and we
really didn't fit in because we forgot
to stay up for four or five days on
drugs committing crimes
before we went in there i mean you go to
an er there's always going to be shall
we say characters there okay right
this was all carrick i did not see
evidence of
anyone suffering from something that had
to do with a pass
like a pathogen or a kitchen knife
accident right okay it was like people
in handcuffs
like people screaming i didn't hear a
sneeze
i didn't hear a cough okay i heard
um obama killed my grandpa you
there was a guy trying to break into the
fridge where they keep like all the
little sandwiches
somewhat you know tweaker who had been
up for i was like rolled tried like
crawling off the cop
pointing the cam like your ankle is big
it was crazy there was and there was
nobody else there that was just like oh
i'm suffering from you know uh something
but it you know how bad it is is the
first
question they asked my husband who's
like the preppiest dude you've ever seen
in your life was
were you injecting drugs in that foot
because that's all they see did you have
his back or were you like where were you
yeah yeah
sitting there in his army lacrosse
hoodie asking him if he's injecting
drugs no
well you know that would be occam's
razor the simplest explanation would be
he was injecting drugs and
not this spider bite but we won't get
into that here
we'll discuss it in the break maybe
we'll have some kind of session
all right hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else